les solutions ce que des gens comme moi
propose en ce moment c'est que à la fin
du confinement ont testé 60 millions de
français
si on continue comme on sait la moi j'ai
un peu peur pour décoincer jusqu'à la
fin janvier
[Musique]
les catholiques de france mobiliser de
nouveau ce dimanche pour réclamer le
retour de la messe dans les églises
alors que les commerces des dons
essentiels devraient rouvrir à partir du
1er décembre le porte-parole du
gouvernement dévoile dans la presse un
allègement du confinement en trois
phases
les modalités devraient être dévoilés
mardi par le chef de l'état
l'opération de charme de l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur aux journalistes
christophe castaner a publié une tribune
dans laquelle ils affirment que la
liberté de la presse est entièrement
préservée et le droit d'informer
consacré l'actuel président les députés
la république en marge des fonds dans le
même temps la loi sécurité globale hier
en france des milliers de personnes ont
manifesté contre l'article 24 jugée
liberticide élections présidentielle et
législatives à haut risque au burkina
faso des régions sous influence
djihadistes privé d'élection des forces
de l'ordre déployées en nombre sur le
territoire hier elles ont tué par erreur
un ressortissant américain
bilan mitigé pour le président sortant
qui brigue un deuxième mandat face à
douze candidats
[Musique]
et
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir le mécontentement
de plus en plus de français vis-à-vis
des restrictions sanitaires avec ces
manifestations maintenant comme chaque
dimanche des catholiques qui réclament
le retour de la baisse dans les églises
plusieurs centaines de croyants à
bordeaux devant le parvis de la
cathédrale saint-andré mobilisation
également à paris devant les églises
saint augustin et saint sulpice
écoutez la co organisatrice du
rassemblement de saint sulpice justement
là l'objectif c'était se rassembler de
c'était de se rassembler devant saint
sulpice on pouvoir réaffirmé le besoin
que les catholiques rond de célébrer la
messe ensemble le dimanche et d'y
assister de façon de façon publique et
dans les églises et pas seulement sur
youtube ou sur zoom mais j'attends de la
part
du gouvernement de prendre en compte le
fait qu'il y ait des milliers de
catholiques qui se réunissent ce
week-end qui se sont réunis déjà pour la
troisième fois consécutive ce week-end
est le cri du coeur beauzire ben voilà
nous on a besoin de la messe c'est
essentiel dans notre vie prenez sa
rencontre la prochaine fois dans vos
protocole sanitaire dans vos mesures
sanitaires ne privez pas les catholiques
de la messe laissez-nous célébrer la
messe de façon publique des français qui
sont toujours dans l'incertitude à la
proche des fêtes de noël emmanuel macron
doit s'adresser à la nation mardi elle
pas de déconfinement mais un
desserrement au progressif en croire le
porte-parole du gouvernement aujourd'hui
dans la presse la gabriela talent a
évoqué un plan en trois étapes d'abord
autour du 1er décembre puis avant les
congés de fin d'année et enfin à partir
de janvier prochain
regardez aujourd'hui le niveau de
circulation du virus dans le pays est le
même qu'au moment du couvre feu
il n'est pas question de les confiner
rien n'est pire que l'incertitude et
l'impression d'une morosité sans fin il
faut de la cohérence de la clarté
un cap savoir ensemble où nous allons et
comment y aller et les commerçants dits
non essentiels devraient être les
premiers concernés par la réouverture
autour du 1er décembre
il demande même de pouvoir le faire dès
le week-end prochain cinq fédérations de
commerçants ont écrit une lettre ouverte
à emmanuel macron dans ce sens il
justifie cette ouverture le week-end
prochain par une meilleure répartition
des flux sur une plus longue période
avant les fêtes de fin d'année et pour
en parler nous sommes ce soir en direct
avec david ducourneau pdg d'une enseigne
de sport de glisse à bordeaux
bonsoir david ducourneau merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france j'imagine
que vous avez lu vous aussi c'est un 10
par rapport à déconfinement progressif
qui n'est pas véritablement un
déconfinement mais en tout cas les
commerces dits non essentiels devraient
pouvoir ouvrir autour du 1er décembre
est ce que vous vous êtes de ceux qui
demandaient aussi à ce que les commerces
rouvrent dès le week-end prochain
bonsoir oui tout à fait on a
effectivement cette volonté de pouvoir
initier une réouverture dès le week-end
prochain ce qui permettrait de lisser la
charge sur un week-end de plus que le
avant noël est donc de permettre d'avoir
moins de couilles sur les dernier
week-end avant avant les sexes oui ça
permettrait évidemment de ne pas faire
l'impasse sur un week-end est essentiel
avant les fêtes alors un des week-ends
les anciens n'avaient d'autre avant
effectivement on a déjà raté beaucoup et
donc effectivement il serait essentiel
je pense pour beaucoup d'entre nous de
pouvoir et l'ouvrir pour pouvoir
recommencer à faire du chiffre
d'affaires et on va entrer dans un cycle
quasi normal on va dire avant dans cette
période vous en tant que pdg d'une
enseigne de sport de glisse c'est à
cette période de l'année que vous faites
le plus gros de votre chiffre d'affaires
effectivement et cdd week-end très très
gros ça a commencé ce week-end si celui
ci convient de passer fermé donc nous on
a une double activité qui est en
commerce et en commerce physique et donc
on a eu effectivement moins d'impact
puisque on a toujours une activité de
e-commerce qui était déjà est
initialisée cependant le décalage du
black friday
toutes les autres activités font que les
chiffres d'affaires ne sont pas un sport
de glisse vous vend des sports de glisse
pour le ski également ou pour pour la
mère fait alors les deux bien sûr mais
avec une grosse spécialité sur les
sports de montagne et donc on attend
aussi avec impatience de savoir comment
se passaient le déconfinement potentiel
des stations de ski voilà c'était ma
question également vous allez pouvoir
vendre ouvertement en présentiel en tout
cas ces articles mais il ya toujours
cette interrogation sur les stations de
ski
on sait que le déconfinement sera
progressif en trois phases autour des
fêtes de noël ça veut dire peut-être pas
une saison complète
quel impact pour votre activité
aujourd'hui il est grand de toute façon
puisque notre activité est une activité
de pleine et donc on l'a fait avant le
départ en vacances donc l'impact et
grands voire très très grand on ne se
rappelle l'estimé le chiffrer avant
d'avoir réalisé le envahir la période
des fêtes de fin d'année mais
aujourd'hui l'impact est très très grand
et je pense qu'il est très très grand
pour la même sûr qu'il soit très très
grand pour toute là l'univers des sports
outdoor est donc tous mes confrères est
aussi fournisseur est donc aujourd'hui
on a un impact qui est très fort sur
l'univers et au toujours une restriction
également qu'il ya un cas un impact sur
ce que vous vendez sceller les personnes
qui ne peuvent pas faire de sport en
tout cas tout fait à plus de deux en
extérieur à plus d'un kilomètre du
domicile est ce que ça aussi c'est ça
une conséquence sur votre activité
oui oui un seul homme tout ce qui est
activités de marche
le running sont plus restreintes on va
dire pendant ces cas là où les gens ne
peuvent se déplacer qu'à un kilomètre de
chez eux donc forcément il ya un impact
je pense que de toute façon la morosité
ambiante et l'esprit n'est pas là pour
faire des emplettes
et donc voilà il faudrait réussir malgré
la situation sanitaire que l'on sait
très compliqué à pouvoir se redonner des
perspectives en fait je pense que c'est
très attendue par tout le monde
c'est au delà de
de tous c'est d'avoir des perspectives
très précises sur sur l'organisation et
la façon dont on doit s'organiser
piloter nos stocks et savoir comment on
va pouvoir imaginer notre atterrissage
de fin d'année plus de lisibilité c'est
ce qu'a promis en tout cas emmanuel
macron qu'attendez-vous dos de son
discours mardi concrètement on espère
clairement alors je parle au nom de
plusieurs fédérations de commerçants de
jeter le parti on espère réellement que
cobac sa veuve rapidement on avait
imaginé le 27
historiquement bon je pense que c'est un
peu un peu raté donc espérons le 28
parce qu'un samedi est un jour de
converse très fort qu'il est présente
presque les autres jours de la semaine
donc il ya il ya forcément cet impact et
qui est très grand donc oui on espère on
espère cette cette capacité à pouvoir
recevoir nos clients de manière
sécurisée de manière par des protocoles
qu'on a déjà mis en place nos petits
commerces on est très très pointilleux
sur le nombre de clients sur les
protocoles sanitaires avec les masques
et les gels et donc là dessus imaginez
avoir la clientèle et refaire notre
métier parce que on est encore une fois
depuis un mois privé de faire notre
métier et c'est d'une complexité grande
aujourd'hui nous on a trente salariés on
a trente salariés qui sont en chômage
partiel et qui attendent de pouvoir
revenir au travail et avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée c'est ce qui devra
sans doute être respectée a annoncé
mardi ce sera suffisant pour vous
adapter pour une ouverture éventuelle
samedi oui oui tout à fait à la ronde et
je pense tous prêts alors on a déjà eu
des échanges en fait sur ce protocole et
on a participé à l'élaboration de ce
dernier l'idée c'est bien entendu de
sécuriser au maximum tout ce qui est
envisageable pour le public
je pense qu'on est tous prêts la
problématique la plus grande encore une
fois et je les ai évoqué c'est la notion
de stock et donc ça on a plus ou moins
selon les différents commerces anticipé
le réassort et où l'achalandage
et donc ce sera la plus grande
problématique mais sur la partie
sanitaire ont mis tous prêts à mourir
dernière question sur la cohérence en
tout cas de ces mesures de restriction
en croire les scientifiques et les
messins l'activité en plein air est
plutôt bénéfique et il n'y a pas grand
risque de contamination
il est toujours interdit d'aller sur les
plages et faire des sports de glisse par
exemple comment comment est ce que
quelqu'un qu'en pensez vous je j'ai fait
la capacité à juger très honnêtement je
pense qu'il est complexe de faire la
dichotomie très précises entre les
différents univers et les différentes
autorisations et interdictions
donc je pense qu'il a été fait des
avances recul parce qu'on maîtrise pas
réellement les éléments et donc qu on
est on est contraint de s'adapter
régulièrement soit la seconde soit aussi
aux réalités sanitaires et donc voilà je
suis honnêtement je ne serai pas
critique personnellement là dessus parce
que bien entendu que ça ne me sert pas
mais pour autant je n'ai pas la maîtrise
scientifique pour pouvoir dire que c'est
une bonne chose ou pas merci beaucoup en
tout cas david ducourneau d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions sur rt
france une situation sanitaire qui
s'améliore en tout cas en france avec 17
1881 nouveaux cas de contamination des
pistes et 2 176 décès supplémentaires à
l'hôpital et un taux de positivité qui
s'élève maintenant à 14,8 pour cent
un virus qui a été détecté pour la
première fois en france dans un élevage
de visons l'abattage d'un millier de
bêtes a été ordonné en conséquence
c'est un fait rarissime qui mérite
d'être souligné christophe castaner
déclare son amour aux journalistes une
opération de communication via une
tribune publiée dans le jdd
après l'adoption du très controversé
article 24 de la loi sécurité globale le
président des députés la république en
marche affirme je cite que la liberté de
la presse est entièrement préservée et
le droit d'informer consacré christophe
castaner qu'ils défendent
même temps la loi sécurité globale et
coûter cher journaliste
nous venons de vivre une semaine pleine
de malentendus qui nous pousse à vous
écrire pour une déclaration d'amour peu
usuelle nous avons parfois eu des
différends c'est vrai il est hors de
question pour nous comme pour quiconque
de s'immiscer dans vos salles de
rédaction dans vos reportages ou sur vos
réseaux sociaux
votre liberté de ton c'est notre liberté
démocratique
aucun article de loi ne devrait
provoquer des inquiétudes quant à nos
libertés mieux protéger les forces de
l'ordre sans jamais porter atteinte à la
liberté d'informer il est désormais
d'une clarté limpide la liberté de la
presse est entièrement préservé le droit
d'informer consacré et voyez ce que dit
de cette tribune
notre éditorialiste politique alexis
poulain les journalistes ne demande pas
des déclarations d'amour déplacés il
demande un cadre législatif qui leur
permet d'exercer leur métier sans
crainte de répression sans crainte
d'être mis en garde à vue sans crainte
d'autres pressions il faut rappeler
pendant la sphère benallal cette affaire
qui a fait trembler le pouvoir
les perquisitions au sein du journal en
ligne mediapart
la convocation d'une journaliste du
monde ariane chemin devant la sécurité
extérieure écrire une tribune de se
tenir là sur la liberté de la presse
avec les revirements du ministre de
l'intérieur
gérald darmanin ministre actuel qui le
mardi disait que les journalistes
devaient aller s'enregistrer auprès de
la préfecture pour couvrir des
manifestations et qui le vendredi 10 90
en fait on va pas changer les lois vous
inquiétez pas tout va bien donc on voit
bien qu'au delà de l'amateurisme fier de
ces gens là il ya une volonté de nuire
une volonté de recadrer de contrôler la
liberté de la presse pour en faire une
presse quasiment aux ordres une
déclaration de christophe castaner qui
intervient au lendemain de plusieurs
manifestations en france des milliers de
personnes dans les grandes villes de
france pour dire non à cet article 24
qui pénalise la diffusion du visage de
policiers il y a eu quelques tensions
hier à paris place du trocadéro vous le
voyez la police a procédé à une
vingtaine d'interpellations
le récit est signé
théo combe du trocadéro à paris ils
étaient plusieurs milliers hier à avoir
répondu à l'appel de syndicats de
journalistes de sociétés de rédacteurs
ou encore d'associations défendant les
droits de l'homme dans le viseur le
projet de loi dit de sécurité globale et
plus particulièrement son article 24 ce
qui se joue c'est tout simplement l'état
de droit en france c'est à dire la
liberté d'informer la liberté de filmer
dans les rues la liberté de rapporter en
témoin ce qu'on voit tout simplement or
l'article 24 modifier ou pas n'y
changera rien l'intention est de museler
la presse
dans aucun pays démocratique on doit
lever le doigt pour demander si on doit
travailler comme journaliste
donc c'est une imbécillité grave
un article qui prévoit de punir d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amendé le fait de diffuser des images
non floutées d'un membre des forces de
l'ordre
une proposition dangereuse pour de
nombreuses personnes présentes sur place
en ce qui concerne la violence policière
mon on a déjà vu pas mal de choses en ce
qui concerne les gilet jaune
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est temps que
le peuple français se réveille et je
suis venue manifester c'est parce que on
peut plus rester derrière son écran sur
les réseaux sociaux un moment il faut
agir
je pense que le peuple de reprendre son
pouvoir finalement avec cette loi la
sphère benalla n'aurait pas existé
puisqu'il n'aurait pas eu les images et
voilà c'est défendre votre métier
défendre ana
un métier aussi qui me tient à coeur
défendre une liberté fondamentale
je pense que c'est à nous même si nous
avons mobilisé tout le monde les jeunes
doivent être là parce que c'est la
société dans laquelle on va grandir et
faucons défendre nos valeurs de liberté
un rassemblement qui s'est déroulé dans
le calme jusqu'aux environs de 17 heures
ils appellent des organisateurs à la
dispersion de la manifestation
quelques minutes plus tard des
échauffourées éclaté entre manifestants
et forces de l'ordre ces dernières ont
alors fait usage de canons à eau et de
gaz lacrymogènes finalement les
policiers ont chargé les centaines de
protestataires
toujours présent sur place des
journalistes ont également été pris pour
cible comme sur ce coup de pied adressé
à un confrère ou encore lors de cette
scène où une journaliste de rtl france a
été empêché de filmer des policiers
rose a circulé ces désordres
si vous circulez pendant les trente
secondes vous êtes à table et c'est
finalement vers 20 heures après deux
dernières invectives que les derniers
manifestants ont définitivement quitté
les lieux devant un parvis des droits de
l'homme
cerné par les forces de sécurité
et voyez ce qu'en pense alexandre
langlois secrétaire général du syndicat
de police vigie pas d'éclipsé john
appliquer les lois existantes tout
simplement c'est que pendant ce qui est
des gens mettent des images dans le but
de nuire aux policiers de l'été physique
ou mentale il risque deux à cinq ans de
prison ces lois ne sont quasiment jamais
appliqué aujourd'hui monsieur darmanin
fait de la communication pour dire
demain ce sera un an de prison
mais c'est ridicule appliquons ce qui
existe déjà comme ça il n'y a pas de
souci sur la liberté de la presse pour
protéger les policiers les lois existent
elles ne sont juste pas piqué demain
celle là ne sera pas plus appliqués que
les autres on est dans de la
communication à bas niveau quand un
gouvernement ne veut pas gym fait une
loi pénale parce qu'il ya personne qui
ira vérifier ce qu'il ya derrière donc
on laisse en l'état des choses ça aurait
été très bien
et deuxièmement cette espèce d'articles
est un peu l'arbre qui cache la forêt
parce que cette loi ne se limite pas
qu'à ça et à la casse complète de la
police nationale vers les polices
municipales et la sécurité privée
il ya beaucoup d'autres choses dans
cette loi qui sont tout aussi graves que
ce droit à l'image
élections présidentielle et législatives
sous tension burkina faso des bureaux de
vote fermaient à cause de menaces de
groupes armés islamistes selon la
commission électorale
depuis la chute de l'ancien président
blaise compaore en 2014 le pouvoir est
confronté à des attaques djihadistes de
plus en plus meurtrières un bilan mitigé
pour le président sortant qui brigue un
deuxième mandat face à douze candidats
un roch marc christian kaboré vous le
voyez qui a voté à ouagadougou le
président sortant a appelé les burkinabé
à aller voter en masse l'opposition elle
dit redouter je cite des fraudes
massives elles menacent de ne pas
reconnaître les résultats
c'est beaucoup
j'appelle donc tous les bouquets n'avait
quelle que soit la tendance à ne pas
faire un peu de paresse parce que il
s'agit de la démocratie de vokoun à face
au il s'agit du développement du burkina
faso et il s'agit également de la paix
dans notre pays donc il est important
que chaque burkinabè aillent voter et
choisir celui qui divise le pays demain
du lac tout le processus électoral
comme vous l'avez vous le constatez
l'opposition politique a toujours agi de
façon républicaine pour préserver la
paix sociale
mais il est notre devoir ici aujourd'hui
collectivement d'interpeller de vie
voilà politique nationale et
internationale pour dire que nous
n'allons jamais accepter des résultats
entachés d'irrégularités
ce matin j'ai informé que certaines
zones sont arrivés notamment facebook md
n'ont pas de numéro
ce qui est bien entendu une porte
ouverte à une fois c'est possible et
voyez à présent de rennes l'analyse de
didier ou aidera au go il est philosophe
et président de la section de france du
mouvement des droits de l'homme et des
peuples du burkina faso
il faut souhaiter que ça n'a pas besoin
que des suspicions de fraudes et que ce
ne soit pas avérée afin que en plus qu'à
aller jusqu'au bout donc dû procéder
travaillent dans un climat beaucoup plus
serein parce que on ça bien sûr
l'attention et on peut craindre
effectivement que ces tensions avec des
équipes
repéré par ci par là ne conduise à un
niveau de violence qu'on n'aurait pas
souhaité que personne ne souhaite
le procureur est générale aucune façon
je vous pourrez du tribunal de grande
instance de bordeaux a sorti un
communiqué sous la terre pour éviter
effectivement prévenir que toute
suspicion ou toute fraude qui seraient
avérées peut être ramener directement
donc devant les tribunaux et par toute
personne qui serait d'en porter dans le
dossier de ce titre moyens les yeux des
moyens pour que les choses se mettent
bien en place et que effectivement on
puisse régler les choses par la voie
judiciaire et non pas donc des méthodes
qui lui seraient contraires et dans la
région du nagorny karabakh les forces
azéries sont en train de reprendre le
contrôle des territoires rétrocédé par
l'accord de cessez le feu
une trêve qui ne signifie pas pour
autant la fin des tensions dit marosi
entre et conquérante dans agdam des
troupes azerbaïdjanaise il ne reste plus
que quelques jours aux forces
arméniennes pour évacuer ce district à
l'est du haut karabagh l'un des trois
rétrocéder à bakou par l'accord de
cessez-le-feu conclu le 9 novembre
dernier devant l'arrivée des forces
azéries les arméniens d'agdam eux aussi
doivent plier bagage comme dans d'autres
régions ils sont nombreux a incendié
leur maison une politique de la terre
brûlée dénoncé par un ilham alief
triomphant
chers compatriotes je vous félicite
chaleureusement pour la libération de la
région d'agdam toutes les
infrastructures restantes tous les
bâtiments maisons monuments historiques
monuments religieux ont été détruits par
l'ennemi sauvage nous avons sauvé la
région du fascisme arménien nous avons
sauvé le monde du fascisme arménien cet
accord de cessez-le-feu est très mal
acceptée par une partie de la population
arménienne depuis sa signature de
nombreuses manifestations ont noirci les
rudes erevan où retentissent les appels
à la démission du premier ministre
arménien nikol pashinian désormais perçu
comme un traître par beaucoup
aujourd'hui nous nous sommes rassemblés
ici pour demander la démission du
traître nikol pashinian un commandant en
chef qui a été vaincu n'a pas le droit
de rester à la tête du pays nous
demandons la démission de nikol
pashinian car il a signé un accord
perfide nikol pashinian a jusqu'à
présent exclu toute démission mais a
d'ores et déjà remplacé trois membres de
l'exécutif le ministre de la défense et
celui des situations d'urgence quelques
jours après le chef de la diplomatie
arménienne contraint à la démission
si d'un point de vue militaire
l'azerbaïdjan est le grand vainqueur de
cette guerre
bakou et son allié turc semble de plus
en plus isolé sur la scène
internationale
car malgré ce gain d'un flux ans dans la
région du caucase ankara fait notamment
face au mécontentement de paris au
prochain conseil européen cette question
turque sera abordée pour voir de quelle
manière on contraint peut être un peu
plus voire beaucoup plus
la turquie parce que son comportement
notamment dans la crise du haut karabagh
est inadmissible
le sénat devrait même adopté mercredi
prochain une résolution non
contraignante demandant la
reconnaissance française du haut
karabagh et la condamnation des
agissements du président turc recep
tayyip erdogan un rôle d'ankara qui doit
aussi être évoquée lors de la prochaine
réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'otan les 1er et 2
décembre prochains et qui a aussi agacé
le chef de la diplomatie américaine en
visite à paris lundi dernier le
président macro et moi avons passé
beaucoup de temps à discuter les actions
récentes de la turquie et nous sommes
tombés d'accord pour dire qu'elle était
très agressive
mike pompéo a d'ailleurs fait escale à
istanbul le lendemain sans même
rencontrer les dirigeants turcs
si en fin de compte la guerre du haut
karabagh version 2020 n'aura duré que
six semaines ses répercussions sur les
relations internationales risque de se
faire ressentir bien plus longtemps
et selon le ministère russe de la
défense le déploiement des 2000 soldats
de maintien de la paix est à présent
terminée des soldats de maintien de la
paix qui devront veiller à la bonne
application du cessez-le-feu sur le
terrain les ministre russe de la défense
et des affaires étrangères qui était
hier en visite
en arménie visites officielles ou
sergueï lavrov s'est entretenu avec le
président arménien ainsi qu'avec le
premier ministre
nikol pashinian qui a déclaré
souhaitable en forcément de la
coopération militaire avec moscou le
chef de la diplomatie russe lui a
insisté sur l'importance du respect du
cessez-le-feu
il a été généralement reconnu que cette
déclaration était la seule voie et qu'il
n'y avait pas d'alternative pour régler
une situation qui était devenue
extrêmement tendu il y a quelques
semaines en catch up
il a été souligné à l'unanimité que
toute tentative visant à remettre en
question cette déclaration au sein du
pays comme à l'étranger et est
inacceptable nous avons réaffirmé notre
volonté de tout faire pour assurer la
mise en oeuvre de cette déclaration les
dirigeants arméniens
nous avons eu une rencontre avec le
président de l'arménie et le premier
ministre ont pris je veux souligner que
cette déclaration avait aidé à résoudre
des problèmes très sérieux et à sauver
des vies sont pleinement attachés à ce
que cet accord soit respectée à l'avenir
le royaume sur corner
la situation tendue au guatemala des
centaines de personnes ont mis le feu
hier au parlement alors qu'une
mobilisation pacifique avait lieu dans
le même temps pour protester contre le
président la police qui a dû disperser
la foule à coups de gaz lacrymogènes en
compte une cinquantaine de blessés
hélas medjahed des flammes gigantesques
ont ravagé l'intérieur du parlement sur
la façade les inscriptions anti
gouvernementales à l'origine de la
colère l'adoption cette semaine du
budget 2021 par le congrès non loin de
là au moment de cet incendie se tenait
une manifestation pacifique devant
l'ancien palais du gouvernement dans le
centre historique de la capitale
nous sommes fatigués parce que le pays
s'endette et on ne peut plus rien
tolérée lors de ce samedi de
mobilisation une vingtaine de personnes
ont été interpellées par la police
les forces de l'ordre qui ont lancé des
gaz lacrymogènes sur la foule malgré la
présence d'enfants ces centaines de
guatémaltèques exigent la démission du
président alejandro jam était à la tête
du pays depuis à peine dix mois pour les
protestataires le chef de l'état est
coupable d'avoir donné son aval au
budget controversée de près de 13
milliards de dollars voté au congrès un
budget qui génère la dette la plus
importante de l'histoire du guatemala
le vice président du pays lui-même
exhortent le président à démissionner
comme au total et j'ai dit très
clairement au président que les choses
n'allaient pas bien sûr de nombreuses
questions gouvernementales et que je ne
suis pas d'accord avec les décisions qui
ont été prises
je n'ai pas été consulté sur ces
questions en raison du manque de
communication que nous avons avec le
président c'est aussi dû à une demande
des citoyens pour nous a dit que les
choses n'étaient pas comme les gens
l'espérer la population déçue de voir
celui jay 2021 destinée surtout à
financer des infrastructures gérées par
des entrepreneurs parlant même de
corruption pour les manifestants le
gouvernement néglige les défis
prioritaires
six habitants sur dix vivent dans la
pauvreté au guatemala et la malnutrition
infantile touche près de la moitié des
enfants de moins de cinq ans et c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve dans 38 reste
avec nous
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être défenseurs du
climat de la nature et des animaux et en
même temps aimait la chasse bien sûr
c'est avoir conscience justement des
populations de comment les gérer si
aujourd'hui on arrive à plus ou moins
trouver un équilibre entre la
l'urbanisation l'agriculture et puis les
espaces naturels c'est grâce à la chasse
grâce aux chasseurs
selon des ong la chasse et la cause de
disparition de certaines espèces j'ai
bien l'impression que les espèces sont
en grande partie conservée grâce à la
gestion des chasseurs aujourd'hui vous
avez vingt trois ans vous êtes une femme
qu'est ce que vous espérez apporter
justement à ce monde de la chaîne